buenas tardes A pesar de la fuerte
lluvia miles y miles de personas
salieron a las calles en especial a las
cercanías del Palacio de buckingham y de
la abadía de Westminster para vivir este
momento histórico querían ser
protagonistas de una u otra manera hacer
los primeros que acompañaran el Rey
Carlos III y a su esposa la reina Camila
en este momento inolvidable para muchas
personas que presenciaron ese momento y
es la coronación del Rey oficialmente ha
ascendido al Trono fue una ceremonia en
esencia la misma desde el año 1066 el
mismo Rito religioso y constitucional
Pero ha hecho algunas adaptaciones para
hacerlo Por ejemplo más corto la
ceremonia duró menos de dos horas y hubo
como lo mencionabas 2.300 invitados a
diferencia de 8.000 que asistieron a la
coronación de la Reina Isabel segunda
hace exactamente
años el momento cumbre de esta
coronación fue el saludo por primera vez
del Rey Carlos III su esposa y pocos
integrantes de la familia real desde el
balcón del Palacio de buckingham El
icono de la monarquía británica y en el
que entonces se oficializa nuevamente y
se le comunica al pueblo como se hacía
en el pasado que un nuevo rey ha sido
Coronado por supuesto la fiesta nacional
sigue aquí en el Reino Unido
independientemente de que se esté o no
de acuerdo con la monarquía porque hay
fiesta programada para todo el fin de
semana festivo este domingo será el
concierto de estrellas cerca del
castillo de Windsor la residencia del
monarca y el lunes festivo será la
oportunidad para que todo el pueblo para
que todo el país
se comprometa con las organizaciones de
Caridad Luisa pues día o días
históricos en Reino Unido pero una
historia que tiene una cara b y
precisamente ha habido varios
manifestantes que han protestado en
contra de la monarquía y ha habido
detenciones en el marco de estas
manifestaciones
sí al menos cuatro personas fueron
capturadas por la policía Metropolitana
de Londres en medio de una manifestación
del movimiento Republic Incluso el
director de esta organización con quien
hemos hablado hace varios días por para
que nos contara el objetivo de esta
marcha Fue capturado por la policía
según ha explicado la policía
Metropolitana de Londres fueron
detenidos bajo sospecha de romper la paz
conspiración para causar molestias
públicas y poseer artículos para causar
daños criminales por supuesto estas
capturas han causado muchísima polémica
especialmente porque la policía había
otorgado el permiso para estas marchas
el gobierno había dicho que era
importante que Quienes no están a favor
de la monarquía
expresaran su voluntad y su opinión Pero
entonces ha causado muchísimo más
polémica estas capturas especialmente
porque hace pocos días la policía
recibió nuevos poderes para hacer este
tipo de capturas